cancer in the large intestine is called
colorectal cancer the parts of your
large intestine are the colon rectum and
anal canal most colorectal cancer starts
in the colon in small clumps of cells
called polyps most polyps are benign
which means they contain abnormal cells
that aren't cancer and won't spread to
the rest of the body they are only in
the thin layer of tissue lining the
inside of the intestine
if the abnormal cells become cancer
cells the polyp can grow bigger and
invade deeper into the wall of the large
intestine if not treated cancer cells
can enter the bloodstream and spread to
nearby lymph nodes over time these cells
can travel to other organs and form more
tumors you may have a higher risk for
getting colorectal cancer if you have a
family history of colorectal cancer have
colon polyps are aged 50 or older are
obese smoked cigarettes aren't
physically active drink too much alcohol
or have a disease that inflames your
colon such as ulcerative colitis or
Crohn's disease symptoms for colorectal
cancer can include a change in bowel
habits such as diarrhea constipation or
having stools more narrow than usual
bright red or dark blood in the stool
feeling unable to empty your bowel belly
pain bloating or cramps unexplained
weight loss feeling weak or very tired
and vomiting it's important to know that
these symptoms can be caused by
conditions other than colon cancer and
it's possible to have colorectal cancer
without any symptoms especially in the
early stages if you have questions about
colorectal cancer talk to your health
care provider